great pleasure and privilege to be
moderating the second panel today it is
especially a great pleasure to be able
to share the diocese with such a
distinguished group of public officials
to my writing if you're left with Dr
Mary Robinson who needs no introduction
to this audience whatsoever
my immediate pride is The Honorable
Richie Neal the congressman from
Massachusetts my native state
to my far left is the vice president of
the European Commission
my immediate left is Sacramento
special assistance in the United States
president and senior director for Europe
at the National Security thank you
so this morning we were all treated to a
very detailed discussion of some of the
Constitutional political cultural and
identity issues facing our job
for this session we want to open the
aperture for a little bit and look at
the meaning of good try
beyond what are
can it serve as a template is an example
it was a model for other conflicts and
particularly for conflict resolution in
other parts of the world
so the first question is
my asking each of the patterns what are
the lesson or lessons that you can draw
from The Good Friday agreement and the
subsequent 25 years
and that you think have applicability
and Communists around the world it's
only served Union copyrights please
thank you well it's been wonderful to be
here and
here as some great Reflections on the
good side of the Belfast agreement I
was president from 1919 to September
1997 and during that time of course I
tried outside the political with groups
of women with cross-community groups Etc
to encourage and visit the Northern
Ireland including to West Belfast
at the time no matter the tradition or
the Irish government really wanted me to
go but I knew it was important and I
never aggressivist but in September 1997
I on one day ceased to be president of
Ireland and under pressure from coffee
Island became the U.N High Commission of
Human Rights extremely stupid I didn't
take a holiday I mean it was crazy but
I then went to my new post as the UN
High Commissioner of the human rights
and during 1998 I was promoting the 50th
anniversary of the universal Declaration
of Human Rights
I actually came down to Belfast in this
December 1998. and I was helped greatly
in
visiting again and making a speech here
by my great friends anyus McCormack
sadly deceased and Martin O'Brien was
ultimately looking out to me I'm here
today and Martin very kindly found the
speech I gave and I hate quoting my own
thinkers but they're just two passages
that I think are highly kind of relevant
to I was speaking as High Commissioner
and I said you know having talked about
Universal declaration I said all of this
is reflected in the Good Friday
agreement which is conspicuous by the
Central Energy appearance between policy
and human rights concerns
few documents emerging from divisive and
difficult political negotiations have so
well captured the importance of fairness
in creating a right relationship and
then I go on if I may just for one
second and your job and future if change
is to be embedded is to ensure that the
various institutions that emerge from
the agreement adhere to the human rights
standard except for them my job is to do
the same thing from the international
level and then I go on one more quote I
also see my role as ensuring that the
International Community learns from your
experience so that the change initiated
here can begin to transform the
relationships elsewhere and still
transform the lives of many so many far
from here and making good on the
Promises of the universal Declaration of
Human Rights and
my bluff was actually called on all of
this when in 2013 I got a different
mandate from a different
Secretary General at the UN I was
invited to be the first woman in a
senior mediation in the Great Lakes of
Africa and it was under an agreement and
called a pact for peace security and
development in the Great Lakes in Africa
and the Democratic Republic of Congo and
I can come back so how difficult I found
this but I was trying
to implement what the Good Friday
agreements so far but maybe you should
hear other families
so the first thing I hope for Madam
president is that nobody will quote some
of the speeches I've made over the years
I've never done that before
so I'm at that point at University
a reputation of international now for a
reform that they've presented the
opportunity for all of us to reflect the
problem I was going to be a nicely
successful part of the American foreign
policy a good
thing there's a danger in anecdotes in
politics but there's also evidence that
frequently comes up every small
conversations and just this morning
coming down from breakfast on the
elevator only introduce himself from the
issue recognized me and
she said I've broken down
she said my childhood was based upon
fear
she said
you couldn't travel
they wanted to go because we were
worried about our own security and then
she sent me something that was very
powerful
she said I wish my grandparents could
come back for one hour
to see their success of what happened
American foreign policy is always a
manifestation of domestic policy it
means that are representative democracy
people within that democracy have a
chance to influence international events
the friends of Ireland was born because
of the violence here in the North
when friends of Ireland served as an
honest broker including a current
president members of Congress and we
insisted
that there'll be a change in policy by
the United States where actually we
would immerse ourselves in the details
of the long-standing political conflict
in the history of the world
reminder
30 years ago there were 30 000 British
soldiers
in an area of the size of our state of
Connecticut
I was here
106 military installations
you couldn't travel anywhere in Belfast
or dairy
without the threat of being stopped and
frisk it had a Congressional Delegation
visit here
in 1989 with the speaker of the house
Tom Ford
our buses stopped and we got about very
border
Keeper of the house for the bus
and searched
my first military
today
the cross what was the Border your phone
payments
that's the reality of what the American
Convention as an honest broker helped to
bring about the other substantive part
of this acknowledgment in an academic
setting which is really important
the world was changing the benefits
really changing the Soviet Union
collapsed and despite the punitive
actions of Putin today
Eastern Europe remains free
part of that was the American guarantee
authoritarian government had come to
South Africa and democracy appeared to
be on the march in places like Central
America and South America there were
free elections you might not like the
result of a free election
but there were free elections
and
there was once governance issue
in the six counties
decent people
every day trying to get on with their
lives
the fact was
the ancient tribal considerations
frequently got in the way
Bill Clinton decided to put something
into it with Hillary Clinton
and I must tell you the friends of our
Ireland lobbied him hard aggressively
and the meetings weren't always Pleasant
and we chose them George Mitchell a
lifelong friend
the Demir of George Mitchell speaks to
everything
he never through that process used
excitable language
Albert Reynolds Bernie Point Blair
everybody decided at Great Risk by the
way and how about do the political
parties and the leaders not just the
political risks here the personal risks
you know one of the hardest things to do
in politics and it needs to be
recognized is to say to your most Ardent
fervent Believers and supporters
we're not going to get what we want
today
but the success of the Good Friday
agreement was because everybody had to
give up something
to get to the Accord
and these institutions need to be up and
running and the government stood up as a
result of everything that America the UK
and the Irish government have put into
it
can't have an election to just have
people say we're not going to abide by
the result of the election there are
many elections in America where I don't
like the outcome
but I accept
what happened
so concessions compromise and consent
convincing people of A New Path that's
what the experience of the Good Friday
agreement
has met and we'll be to he or she who
makes the argument you can move away
from the good fighting agreement America
as you've heard for the last three days
we as a co-guarantor of that agreement
we are all in
thank you
of first and foremost I really would
like to thank the quiz University
Developers for hosting already for the
second time because I was here in
September 2021 because I just wanted to
continue this very intensive interaction
we had with all political leaders in
Northern Ireland and also with the
Pacific Society I think the professor
could say Hayward has been marvelous
European working with the communities in
putting it into the metrics how the
opinion pools are evolving in a Northern
Ireland and of course we've been
listening very very carefully to all the
representatives of the business T here
in Northern Ireland what is native what
what I heard quite clearly was we need
predictability we need stability we need
a vision of peace and we need division
of prosperity and therefore if you ask
me what are the lessons to learn from
Good Friday doctors agreement I think
first and foremost for me it would be
the inclusivity that you have to listen
carefully to All actors and therefore
we've been developed on the outset that
we want to work together with our UK
partners and with all actors in Northern
Ireland
to deliver something which would work
well for all communities because it has
to be it has to be the the joint effort
and I think uh if I look back in 1998 it
was my first day when I started this
ambassador of Slovakia in Israel but I
was I can tell you I was glued to the TV
screen because I was watching the the
days of the negotiation so they both
Friday's office agreement to see the
vision
see the Hope which was created by this
deliberation the people celebrating in
the industries that the peace has come
to the streets of Belfast and other
cities in the Northern Ireland and
across the whole island before Ireland
and I think that you need also to build
the positive emotion around the
negotiations which I think was so well
translated into huge political support
look at the referendum results 71 or
more than 90 percent of support it's
remarkable lets you have you have a
successful consensus that we want to
move on we want to assure the new era
and we want to focus not only on peace
for those who want increased prosperity
and I'm very happy that this afternoon
with uh Tony Stark also with the with
secretary uh Chris it in Harrisburg also
with the U.S Envoy for Northern Ireland
Mr Kennedy but also discussing you know
this perspective of these new economic
prosperity for for Northern Ireland
because I think that after 25 years of
peace now we need to focus how you can
combine the peace with increased
prosperity for the uh for the Northern
Ireland and I think it's achievable it's
all very Democratic Dynamics in our
previous style so I think the Democracy
reside on healthy in Northern Ireland so
it is up to the people of Northern
Ireland how they decide to move it
forward but I think that the discussions
like we had today
University the interaction and and
highlighting what kind of opportunities
this new situation brings to the island
of Ireland will be the markers which I
think will resonate with all political
leaders
[Applause]
I thank you I have extended the audience
yesterday and listened to so many Giants
of the the peace process speak it's it's
a real honor to to be sitting up up here
today uh when the Good Friday agreement
was signed I was in the midst of mine
PhD at the University of Edinburgh and
it's to Belfast at the beginning of
September 2001 so just three years after
the agreement was signed and there was
peace but it was a fragile piece
Holy Cross was was kicking off it made
international news including in the U.S
my parents and Friends very concerned
about my decision to to move to Northern
Ireland just after over a week after I
got here 9 11 happens nobody ever again
asked if I felt safe in Belfast and
people spoke a lot yesterday about the
empathy and the compassion that the
people in Northern Ireland and I have to
say if I could not be in my own country
on such a terrible day it was really
profound to be in a place like Northern
Ireland
the people knew firsthand
what terrorism and what living through
those types of experiences was like my
boss here at Queens University was
Elizabeth Meen
several years ago and I know would have
fully appreciated
she invited me over to her house she
told me to call my friends and family
she ordered Curry and we sat there on
her couch and over and over again
watched those terrible images from that
day and then as I was getting ready to
go home she gave me a nightgown and told
me to spend the night so felt fully
embraced by her and by the people here
that Friday there was a memorial service
outside City Hall and I see Barbara
Stevenson in the audience who was the
newly arrived Thompson General Ben and
she stood on the stage flanked by
political leaders and religious leaders
from both communities and said to them
the thing you can do to most help us is
to find peace amongst yourselves
and so it's somewhat of the inverse of
the question on this panel but it was an
interesting example of how a terrible
tragedy in the United States ended up
being yet another impetus to the the
peace process here
morning of 9 11. I know Jerry Adams was
in Dublin meeting with Richard Haas who
was President Bush's Envoy team on
Ireland
talking about some engagement that the
IRA had been having
RPA in Columbia and I think the
experience of Colombia and also the way
in which the terrorist attacks in the
United States resonated with the
American people the way it shaped how
they looked at terrorism
including Europe Northern Ireland led to
an announcement six weeks later by the
IRA to start the decommissioning process
uh several weeks after that the psni was
stood up
flatmate who was a young Catholic woman
who just graduated from Queen's
University
and been very cagey with me when I moved
in about what her career plans were told
me that she was in the first class of
Catholic groups uh
and so I saw firsthand through her
experiences the reality of what police
saying in Northern Ireland was like I
worked as a special advisor to the
committee of finance and personnel
the mundane business
uh storm it was doing was looking at the
types of EU funding
I had a friend who worked for the
Northern Ireland women's college student
so I went out with Monica McWilliams and
others and and knocked doors so I worked
as a whole clerk at one of the elections
and really saw firsthand on a day-to-day
basis what great people in Northern
Ireland were doing to preserve and to
implement peace
and I mentioned Columbia briefly and it
was one of those places years later that
really ended up looking to Northern
Ireland as as a model and when I left
Northern Ireland and moved back to the
U.S in 2005 worked for the national
Democratic Institute which also took a
number of political leaders from
different countries including Iraq where
I worked at
here to show people an example of a
multi-sectarian multi-faith
divided society that was able to
implement and develop structures to find
a way foreign
[Applause]
respect for human rights and equality
from Congressman it was the importance
of the role of the United States in The
crucial variable of leadership making a
huge difference
in our shiftwoods inclusivity and having
a vision that people can unite around
and become inclusive
and Amanda's fear of sense of empathy
that came through along with the
detailed knowledge of the local
landscape all of those I think clearly
were part of what made the Good Friday
agreement such a success and perhaps
transcended and have lessons for other
conflicts around the world
but here we are in the heart of a great
University one of the best in the entire
world and there are probably young
people here
in the room and perhaps watching around
the world and so perhaps we can offer
some lessons for them as a future
negotiators of conflict resolution of
peace agreements what are some of the
qualities that you feel that you need
that you need to bring to the table when
you're negotiating is intractable
problems very difficult people if the
problems were easy they would have been
solved by the time you got there
so what are the personal qualifications
or characteristics that you think are
most useful in negotiating peace
communities
well thank you that's all I might
illustrate with my personal experience
in agnostic videos on that pact for
peace facility and development in the
Great Lakes in Africa and the German
Catholic Republic of Congo that's the
title
I had to reframe this as a pact of Hope
and I want to involve civil society and
particular women
um
it was very difficult
I learned a lot from listening to the
television at this campus and one thing
that I absolutely agree with was the
empty Sense on the need to nurture
implementation of an agreement so you
get the words on paper and get the
vision Good Friday Belfast agreements
but you need to really reinforce and
fulfill the objectives so I had 13 heads
of state
of countries of Africa I had four
institutions the United Nations the
African Union and the great lakes and
the organization itself and static from
Southern Africa all Representatives at
head and state level
they were all pretty well all men there
was one woman and a joystander was I was
hypothetic for a while
um
it was a Secretariat formed nominated by
these sentences they all nominated men
I got vintage who was a great friend of
mine and she was the special
representative of the African African
Commission on women peace and security
to join I nominated I didn't have a
right turn on me but I noticed and so
she was one and when I was in places
like Roma and meeting with civil society
I realized that in the culture very
often women wouldn't see God so there
were times that I literally that are
short of time myself and I said look and
this has been very good I'm glad to have
heard you now I want to listen to the
women so men get out let me let me talk
to someone and then I would hear you
know the the serial rate that was going
on I don't know violence which will
never be spoken about unless you get the
group together Etc and I eventually
ended up supporting and forming a
platform of women's groups from the four
key countries from the DRC from Rwanda
from Uganda and from Burundi and that's
still going I'm about to say and I
follow Elizabeth in
you just don't you know you don't easily
make and sustain peace if only we
understood how precious we
Good Friday Belfast agreement is and
that is has been emphasized that there
is a process here for the people of
Northern Ireland which is beyond price
it's invaluable it's rare
very rare at the international level as
I know from my work as even high
Commission of a human right so now let's
hear the illness but we're still trying
to of course address some conflicts so
you know it's wonderful to be here I
hope that this commemoration and
benefits so well planned by Queen's
University I've had great tributions to
the planning of this will help encourage
valueing and now implementing fully this
very special Good Friday Belfast
agreement
I think one of the most difficult things
in negotiating
significant
legislation is to know how far your
opponents can go
and then to give him some room
to bring it back the information to
their supporters
and they try to push to get a little bit
more
but don't listen very carefully but to
always acknowledge the realities of
where we find in ourselves
example the three strands of the Good
Friday agreement
North Southeast Western British Heights
and three strands of the Good Friday
agreement there were two seismic moments
in the negotiation
one when the Republic of Ireland gave up
its constitutional argument for articles
with the Constitution that made plank
for six counties and k
I gave up the war now with brexit some
began to argue that well maybe there
could be a return to a hard border I
want to say this based on what Joe body
magic Watson I have said repeatedly
there could be no return to a hard order
on the island of Ireland
thank you
being able to Journey back and forth
from Belfast to Dublin which is straight
into or he agreement
this changed everything for young people
and their aspirations two generations
have now grown up here not normal
about the violence and I returned to the
French that I offered early on the risk
that people took to bring about those
two big achievements
and when we think of it
it becomes a template for the rest of
the world
but at the same time
when we reach our potential our
potential expense
thank you
foreign
I would say that the message would be
the diplomacy or I would say
negotiations in politics it's not easy
as my mom says it will be easy everyone
else would do it so I mean it's it's
really a challenging task but you have
enormous sense of accomplishment and
delivering the public service if you
succeed and it's it's something which I
mean kind of keeps you motivating
because you you know that you are trying
to do the the good thing and find the
best possible solution for all the for
all the parties I would say the lesson
number one is respect your partner know
your father go into the details because
that could allow you to kind of
understand better what are the
limitations of your of your partners
work with your partners but also work
with your own constituents because in
the end you will have to find the
solution which might be kind of
difficult also for your own party and
therefore sometimes the change of the
mindset the new approach to solving the
problems being creative I think it's
it's very very important so we have to
kind of work on both sides with your
with your negotiating parties but also
with the party you represent or you you
trying to convince about the the the the
solutions you are you are you are
working on and I think that respect
should be demonstrated in the room and
outside of the room because you need to
be very honest with you with your
partners but also to be I would say very
very honest and positive about them when
we are talking to the price when we are
talking to other parties because the the
world is actually very very small and
and I mean it's very difficult to to
trust your partner negotiator when you
know that there is this lack of respect
so I think it's it's a big part of that
is I would say also the establishment of
this strong personal relationship I'm so
happy that with both James Cleveland
Harris in very short period of time he
managed to to have that strong strong
relationship I always remember the very
positive atmosphere we had on the hill
with with the congressman Richard Neal
but also with the other caucus in
support of U.S Administration and of
course a big support among the member
states in the in the European Union in
the end I think we've been all very
proud the European Union was at the at
the site of the of the peace process in
Northern Ireland from from the Dane one
from the first announcement of the
ceasefire it was still rejected a lot of
us how can we help what can we do and I
think that through all the peace
programs and the facilities and the
financing it just to be a good friend
not to meddle in but to be always ready
to to assist and help I have seen
fantastic project from schenkel Road
women's center community schooling Peace
Bridge flurry Bridge you know Aria being
transformed from from military ground
into the striving business community and
all these are I would say very practical
things which kind of demonstrate to the
people of Northern Ireland that there is
very strong peace dividend and there is
more to come if you if you if you work
in in that direction
coming back to my initial arguments I
have such a personal
personal I would say rule for myself
that sometimes of course these
discussions could be very frustrating I
should Madame President then Richie
would confirm sometimes there is a
disappointment sometimes there is a
failure but
never try to always try to have the
evening conclusion of the conversation
in a way then you can have a coffee in
the morning video partner never break it
off never push it beyond the state of
repair because in the end it's always up
to you to come back to the deal to come
back to the table and work harder for
finding the solution and for that you
need to have that utmost respect for
your partner you need to build a strong
personal relationship and you have to
build that relationship of trust which
is I think it's such a crucial equality
for any successful negotiations
talking about
foreign
I think everybody has has hit on on many
of the the key things either the one the
one message I would I would give to the
the students here especially the the
women students here is please go into
government uh I know there's more money
to be made in finance there is more
money to be made in in Tech uh politics
and and government don't always get the
the best reputation uh but we need a new
generation of leaders uh to bring A New
Perspective
and I think you you have to follow your
your passion in in what you're doing I
certainly I never expected over 20 years
ago when I was sitting here that I would
be returning one day with with the
president of the United States uh but
but had a passion for for European
politics was deeply interested in in
what was happening here and it's always
good if what you study in the University
becomes relevant at a later point in in
your life uh in terms of approach to
negotiations I the the fellow panelists
have have hit on many of them and there
was there was clear themes that were
coming out of yesterday one one
obviously is is the importance of
including women uh and it was discussed
in in the women's lunch yesterday and I
can't remember what the the actual
statistic was but it was looking at the
greater longevity of peace agreements
that are concluded with the involvement
of of women
uh second George Mitchell spoke
incredibly eloquently yesterday about
the importance of of listening uh and I
think just having the opportunity to
hear people and and deeply understand
what it is they're saying uh third
everybody has focused as well on on the
importance of implementation and I think
the reality that that sometimes
institutions and systems are designed to
stop a conflict uh and then things
evolve and and things need to evolve uh
with them uh
uh and the final piece I think is the
importance of of the economic aspect uh
you're seeing this in in societies with
the need to ensure young people are are
fully employed that people have hope
that people have a perspective on the
future uh and I think it really was the
message that the president was wanting
to deliver when he was here last week uh
the last 25 years have been about the
peace the importance of ensuring the
next 25 years are about the prosperity
and taking full advantage of the peace
dividend that has been put in place here
and ensuring that we can capitalize on
it to the benefit of everyone in
Northern Ireland
thank you thank you
so one of the common themes from all of
our panelists is really the importance
of communication both communicating and
receiving Communications and
understanding what that means now we all
know that social media didn't exist 25
years ago
but I'm curious what you think how has
social media today impacted negotiations
both in terms of the trust that Marsh
was talking about in terms of
understanding the opponent's view in
terms of communicating to your own
constituency and in terms of other
voices other stakeholders perhaps
aggravating
increasing the difficulty putting more
pressure in real time on negotiations
because that's a reality that we all
face today it's something you can't
pretend doesn't exist it's part of
the variables that make up any
negotiation today and you have to be
able to handle it so Dr Robinson how how
do you evaluate that today and how what
advice would you give it's certainly
true I had to actually travel on one day
and meet five presidents of Africa on a
tricky tricky situation and I'll tell
you a funny story briefly and I was my
office was in Nairobi I'd been and seen
president kid weighty in Tanzania I was
going on to president kagani in Rwanda
and I was staying in Nairobi in the and
I came to the VIP early in the morning
and the plane taxied down the runway and
phone calls had to be made and the plane
came back for me and they're air Kenya
flights out I never forget it's the only
time that could ever have happened but
and that's a there's a lot of pressure I
think that it's very important
to try to understand what is the fear
and resistance to an agreement more and
rather than you know
pressure of the wrong kind
help
those who are fearful to overcome
through and I think this conference will
hopefully hurt and I would have liked to
have seen more representation for
example the dup here I thought
the panel this morning was very good
because it shows the different
perspectives and it did show you know
that there are still fears that there
are still worries I think we have to be
terribly uh you know kind of recharge as
much as possible in order to
secure for the whole people of Northern
Ireland the full flowering of this
agreement it is ready to flower there's
no doubt about that and I think the
Windsor framework was very helpful in
you know sorting out a lot of nutty
naughty issues it's clear there is
Goodwill from the United States and
money behind that Goodwill there is huge
support from the European Union Northern
Ireland is very lucky I mean you know
for a relatively small population to be
to have these connections and to have
this support I can think of Yemen I can
think of what's happening to women now
in Afghanistan I can think of all kinds
of places that aren't getting the
support and I just wanted to reinforce
one point
um that that you made about the role of
women in peace processes I see Milan
Revere down there in the audience with
her incredible Institute for women peace
and security and how helpful you were to
be in my work
um
recently with Monica McWilliams and all
of us over there and I think this has
helped to highlight the importance but
it's it's more than that and we have to
build in now
um the role that women play on the
ground and make it part of Peace
processes and make it part of the
implementation and have them at the
table you just have to do that more it's
still not happening enough
thank you
so I'm glad that we would not be trying
to negotiate the Good Friday agreement
in the age of social media
you sit in a room now in Washington
where you're sworn to secrecy and
confidence building
and as you walk out the door
reporters and others
have knowledge of what you've just said
you've done
our job is not to entertain the voters
our job is to inform the voters
and I call attention to that because in
complicated negotiations the reward more
and more seems to be
how do you stop something from happening
rather than having it happen
and the critics know just where to put
the needle in with excitable language
they know the
media Outlet you go to that's going to
confirm what you think rather than the
opposite
and social media creates instant opinion
how many times in our own lives
have we believed something only six
months later to say how could I have
believed that
upon reflection and I think that it
plagues the Western democracies now
disinformation which is carefully
calculated versus misinformation which
can
suggest that somebody says misinformed
but it's harder and harder in the
western democracies now to get big
things done and the other part of it is
back to what happened with the Good
Friday agreement the compromises that
were built in
compromise is not akin to treason
compromise means that even though in
this moment we can't get what we want
if we're patient enough
if we use the process of democratic
institutions
we can Prevail over a prescribed period
of time but social media which is really
playing our ability in Washington
to get big things done
so we are outraged immediately and we're
not and we understand that our lesion
well it's it's also uh as I said a
moment ago what's happened to Media it's
called confirmation bias you go to the
media Outlets
agrees with you
and rather than a Discerning media
because it's harder world of social
media to do context
you know columnists and others used to
explain things as to why you did what
you did
it's hard to do that in a tweet it's
really hard to do that in a tweet which
engulfs raw emotion at that moment
right solution
well I mean my own prescription is that
uh
I think the voters should reward those
who have the great patience of
understanding that in Democratic
institutions
you sit sometimes in a room as I did
with usmca the largest Trade Agreement
in the history of the world
day after day when people say you can't
get an agreement not only do we get an
agreement 195 Democrats voted for a
trade agreement
and 194 Democrats I'm sorry 194
Republicans voted for the trade
agreement
you sit there and again and you say to
yourself I can't believe what they just
said but you don't say that publicly
and you say if they say that again I'm
going to get up and leave and then what
you said that you don't have to believe
but I think that the pain
the paint wears thin now
because of social media and again the
reward politically in the western
democracy now seems to be leaning
against achievement
and the fundraising aspect of it oh the
social media being used to generate
donations you've got to what you have to
do is you have to generate conflict 24
hours a day and outrage and it becomes
harder and harder if you're a serious
legislator
when you're responding to information
that is nonsense never mind misinformed
I think my
lessons from negotiations and of course
these huge social media uh presence
which is inevitable will always be like
this I think that the communication part
of the negotiation process is becoming
as important as the negotiation
negotiation themselves so coming back to
the trust among the negotiators must be
built also on the fact that
we are going to communicate
moralize along the same lines
if there is any let's say communication
crisis that will talk to each other that
our communication advisors would be on
on top of it that we are not going to
entertain the public as as a congressman
said that we will we are not going to
provide the kind of running commentary
on on the on the issue and that we have
to uh focus our minds on what is our job
is to get an agreement to find the
solution is to bring the resolution to
the issue we had on on the table and to
that we have to also adjust our
communication policy so communication
discipline trust I would say certain
attempt to create through I would say
confidentiality of the discussion the
negotiations face
for everyone who is involved I think
it's uh it's it's crucially important
otherwise it's becoming very difficult
because especially if you are
in in the situation and all these
important negotiations are politically
very very sensitive and immediately we
kind of generate the the pushbacks the
political Clash or create I would say
it's very difficult political noise
that's extremely complicated to focus on
on the substance of the problem you have
to you have to resolve so I think that
from now on for
all future negotiators of the difficult
sensitive Deals they have to have very
strong communication advisors and the
communication policy has to be part of
the negotiations because that's the only
way how we can handle these difficult
negotiations
thank you thank you
very sensitive Place lots of social
media lots of opinions yes I also
Congressman said lots lots of opinions
in in Washington I you know I had I had
the same initial reaction as him which
it's a it's difficult to imagine the
Good Friday agreement being negotiated
now I mean you could imagine sort of
negotiators walking out and tweeting and
somebody taking photographs of working
documents and and things getting tweeted
out although that said I give a
tremendous amount of credit to the EU
and the UK which managed to negotiate
the Windsor framework in a very closed
and quiet way which which does show if
you have people on both sides committed
to Serious good faith negotiations even
in this time of social media it is
possible to keep things uh private to
block out the outside noise and and to
get things done I you know at its its
best social media can be ineffective
tool for government it can be a way to
get out information to reach people that
you might not otherwise to present
information uh in in new and and
creative ways and again I think this is
another reason why we need uh the next
generation of of leaders uh who will
will help us harness hopefully a lot of
this new technology in in ways that it
can ultimately be used for productive
purposes rather than a harmful ones
great thank you thank you
so our session is coming to a close I
want to thank Queens University again I
want to thank all of you and I
especially want to thank my
distinguished panelists
for I hope it was a very informative and
interesting conversation thank you very
much